(Applause)
Thank you.
(Music)
♫ Slide into the shimmering surface ♫
♫ between two worlds. ♫
♫ Standing at the center of time ♫
♫ as it uncurls. ♫
♫ Cutting through the veil of illusion. ♫
♫ Moving beyond past conclusions. ♫
♫ Wondering if all my doubt and confusion will clear. ♫
♫ If I could be anywhere, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere right now, ♫
♫ I would want to be here. ♫
♫ Searching for the future ♫
♫ among the things we're throwing away. ♫
♫ Trying to see the world ♫
♫ through the junk we produce everyday. ♫
♫ They say nothing lasts forever, ♫
♫ but all the plastic ever made is still here. ♫
♫ And no amount of closing our eyes ♫
♫ will make it disappear. ♫
♫ If I could be anywhere, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere in history, ♫
♫ I would want to be here. ♫
♫ The Romans, the Spanish ♫
♫ the British, the Dutch, ♫
♫ American exceptionalism, so out of touch. ♫
♫ The folly of empire repeating its course, ♫
♫ imposing its will ♫
♫ and ruling by force ♫
♫ on and on through time. ♫
♫ But the world can't take it very much longer. ♫
♫ We're not going to make it ♫
♫ unless we're smarter and stronger. ♫
♫ The world is going to shake itself free of our greed ♫
♫ somehow. ♫
♫ If I could be anywhere, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere in time, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere and change things, ♫
♫ it would have to be now. ♫
♫ They say nothing last forever, ♫
♫ but all the plastic ever made is still here. ♫
♫ And no amount of closing our eyes ♫
♫ will make it disappear. ♫
♫ And the world can't take it ♫
♫ very much longer. ♫
♫ We're not going to make it ♫
♫ unless we're smarter and stronger. ♫
♫ The world's gonna shake itself free of our greed ♫
♫ somehow. ♫
♫ And the world can't take it, that you can see. ♫
♫ If the oceans don't make it, neither will we. ♫
♫ The world's gonna shake itself all the way free ♫
♫ somehow. ♫
♫ If I could be anywhere, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere in time, ♫
♫ if I could be anywhere and change the outcome, ♫
♫ it would have to be now. ♫
(Applause)
Thank you.